Kamath thrones original pilot we filmed
it in Morocco those of you who follow to
show me know there was a there was
another pilot before the pilot that you
saw there were several recasting and we
we shot so in the original pilot Cobb
Drogo was was still it was being played
by Jason Momoa but the part of the
Daenerys Targaryen was being played by
Tamzin merchant a very talented young
British British actress and we had with
were filming the scene in the Moroccan
desert of of Danny and drogas wedding
and of course Drogo gives Dany at the
climax of that wedding Drogo gives to
any silver horse which he just calls her
silver a beautiful beautiful horse and
she mounts the horse and going in the
book here she mounts the horse and you
know we've we've been in in the book
we've been in her head and we know how
frightened she is and how much she
doesn't really want to be part of this
wedding and etcetera etcetera and she
mounts the horse and she sort of rides
away in this you know and there's a big
fire in the middle of the camp here
where there with a huge fire pit and we
think for a moment that my god is she is
she trying to run away from her wedding
is she is she fleeing and there's some
suspense but she actually rides the
horse out she proves that she getting
ride and then she turns the horse around
and comes galloping back through the
camp and faster and faster and then
horse leaps over the fire pit leaps over
the fire and and this endears her to
Drogo here admires her courage and you
know although she's not a experienced
writer that chief actually was willing
to try this this just fire leap and he
you know it's it it wins her a lot of
status at the finish so it's sort of a
semi important kind of moment there and
we were we were going to include this in
the original pilot and we got we got one
of the best stunt writers in Europe and
flew her down to Morocco to double for
Tamsin in the scene and we we had this
the silver the the filly that she's
given a beautiful silver white horse
that was supposedly a stunt horse and
you know we had this nut right there
with her silver weight method on a horse
and righty and no way that that horse
was jumping over that [ __ ] fire they
tried for half the night and the horse
would come approaching the fire and
would veer right would veer left would
just jerk to a stop you know and then
weave they finally said okay we can't
the horse is not going to jump the fire
so we'll put the fire out and the horse
will jump over the burned logs and then
we will put in the fire with CGI later
no the horse knew there used to be a
fire there wasn't gonna jump the logs
either so we had to lose the whole most
of the sequence you know and which is
one of the things that happens when
you're when you're filming you'll run
into these practical challenges and then
what happens later in in the books is
Drago and Danny right out to to
consummate their marriage and you have
the the wedding night
consummation scene which is quite
different in the final game of Thrones
as aired than theirs in the book the
original pilot followed the the book
much more closely so you know you just
have you have Danny and Drogo riding out
and they find this little secluded spot
as a stream and you know their Drogo
doesn't speak any English so they're
talking to each other and and she says
no the only words you know and they
undress and you know this is there's a
sex scene which was pretty sexy and and
fairly romantic we're filming this at
night in the in the Moroccan desert it's
a hundred and twenty during the day
and like 30 at night so I don't know how
our actors did it but Tamsin and Jason
are you know naked there and there
they're filming the scene of course and
so it's only them them and there are two
horses that are tied to the trees of
course behind the camera there are 120
people with you know platforms and
lights and sound equipment and all that
and doing that and those of us backed by
the trucks watching it under video
cameras here and so I'm sitting there
watching them as they do this a fairly
hot sex scene and one of the people
starts laughing and then other people
start laughing and what's going on there
so we go over to the video cameras to
see what they're laughing at and what
became apparent is that is that the
Danny is horse the beautiful silver
filly was not in fact a filly seem to be
getting turned on by the we were seeing
this enormous silver schlong maybe
that's why they decided to change it all
you'll notice in the final version doing
films with us with a million Clark there
are no horses anyone's entirely bail
horses so they the sex of horses is a
problematical issue both for me and rose
add further filming I know think that
was very popular and people wanted to
kiss a categoric statement from you on
this because a lot of people think that
HBO gave up the whole Renly and Loras
relationship and that old people are
saying oh they're not getting the books
that's absolute rubbish no those people
are wrong they are they are lovers in
the book I hesitate to use the word gay
because there's actually a a modern word
oh and
that was only applied to you know the
homosexual relationships I think in the
late 60s early 70s was when it acquired
that that meaning but yet Loras and
Renly were always intended to be to be
involved with each other romantically
and sexually and to be lovers and there
are numerous places where that is
indicated in in the in the books it is
indicated subtly since neither of them
is a is a viewpoint character but it's
it's there you know I actually like
subtlety you know one of the things that
the HBO I mean television by its very
nature is less subtle you know they
there's a certain you don't want the
audience to be confused you you don't
want to leave so much ambiguity but
prose is a different thing and as a
novelist
I like subtlety I like ambiguity I like
leaving things that my readers need to
figure out and some of them will find it
and some of them maybe won't find it and
then they'll be discussing it with each
other and safe did you notice this thing
in the other day oh my god I didn't
notice that but now that you say yes of
course that's true I think that's one of
the pleasures of of reading and
discussing the books that you've read
with other people what television is is
different so